he uh went over whatever over 20 or
something and then
something switched and he went five for
nine right
overnight zero for 25 to five for nine
right and this is the one thing that
switched and this is how i want to share
it with you
[Music]
good morning everyone it is 4 30 a.m
rocking in from uh downtown austin or
not downtown austin suburbia austin um
but
i am knee-deep in creating our new phone
sales training um
super robust to end and training for our
glx files um
and jim lords and so i'm i'm very very
excited about how it's coming out it's
one of some of our best stuff
um but while i was going through it
there was this one kind of way i phrased
something that i
really liked and i wanted to share it
with you
which is uh uh one of our one of our uh
gyms
uh had been really struggling with sales
and uh he gets on the daily call every
day which is why we encourage people to
do it
um where i just coach all of our gyms
one-on-one and um
he heard something which was to the to
the extent of
remember why you're doing this right
remember why you're caring about the
customer
now here's where this gets really cool
he uh went over whatever over 20 or
something and then
something switched and he went five for
nine right
overnight zero for 25 to five for nine
right and this is the one thing that
switched and this is how i want to share
it with you
he essentially the person who wins
so every every sale is the same right
and a sale is always made either they
sell you or you sell them
but who is the person who makes the sale
the person who makes the sale is the
person who cares the most about the
buyer
think about that for a second and so
that's the phrasing that i'm using in
the training
is the person who cares the most about
the buyers interests
is the one who will win the sale all
right like this was super profound for
me
and so when you're approaching the sale
you have to come at it from the
perspective of
i care more about this person than this
person cares about themself
and this is what that gym owner was able
to flip in his mind
was he remembered why he was he said
because i give him the term commission
breath
right people can smell whether you're in
it for their for your agenda or their
agenda
right and so if you want to win the sale
you have to come at it from the
perspective that i care more about your
best interest than you do
right you're gonna throw these things in
my way
but i care about you enough to get us
through them so we can get to the
promised land which is you getting help
which is why you're here
right and you have to expect that you're
going like
the sale is not going to go the way that
you imagine in your head because people
bring all this emotional baggage
to the sale and it's a problem that's
covered in shame and guilt
which which is a great uh a great way of
saying uh
it's not easy to get people to to trust
you to build rapport so they can
actually be real with you
the moment you're able to get someone to
be real with you in the sale you've
already won the sale right because at
the end of the sale
if for some reason they actually can't
afford it which is a very very very very
very very very small percentage of
people
then you're on the same side of the
table with them and it's like cool then
let's actually figure this out together
but you're coming from it from a
perspective that they trust
that you are acting in their best
interest right and so that's
ultimately the sale that's that's being
made is that the person
needs to trust that you care more about
their agenda than they do
think about it that's the sale that's
being made
if they believe that you care more about
them
genuinely than they care about
themselves or have demonstrated
care about themselves then you will win
and so that's why
i see some of our gyms who honestly
aren't the most skilled sales people
but they kill it and i cause i know
these guys because there's some guys who
are just
very process oriented they follow the
[ __ ] script and they crush it right
and that's great and i know why those
people are successful because they were
successful at everything
but there's some people who are quote
personality driven sales people
and these are like the really genuinely
kind-hearted caring people that you can
immediately tell from their vibe that
they really love fitness and really love
helping people get in shape and lose
weight and take control of their lives
those people get away with so much
lack of skill in the sale but are able
to close
because the people believe that they
really are acting in their own best
interest right
which is why having conviction in your
product is so important
and so if you can simply have that one
reframe
before you go into the sale which is i'm
going to approach this from the
perspective that this person
needs my help but like actually though
like actually getting them to like you
actually believing that they need your
help and that you
have to have their true best interest at
heart
more than they do which is why if you do
genuinely have that belief you're going
to force them to confront the limiting
beliefs that they had
right and you'd be like listen like let
me be real with you here
like do you think that the reason that
you haven't been successful is because
like
you've you've kind of just like fallen
off the bandwagon
like you've you've been putting the food
in your mouth right
so that's whose responsibility is that
is that is that your busy schedules is
that your husband who's
whose responsibility is that right
they're like well i guess it is mine
you're like right
and i'm not saying this to be mean to
you i'm saying this because i want to
help
but this time is going to be different
right and so that way you can break
these beliefs systematically throughout
so you can actually help this person
all right because sales is just coaching
right with an
outcome that's defined over a period of
time and so
i guess the biggest point that i want to
make here is that if you can just think
about it from that perspective
this guy had the same script from his
first you know
25 reps to the the last five of nine
that he hit
right and mind you he made this
realization at rep 25 which for some
reason is a magical number
all right but at rep 25 he realized that
he just was trying to sell on his agenda
and not on the agenda of the other
persons and there's sometimes it's it's
uh
i mean one of the things that i was just
talking to our sales team about is
advanced salesmen are advanced because
they never don't do the basics
right people are defined as advanced
because of their outcomes not because of
their tactics
all right advanced lifters aren't doing
different tactics than novice lifters
they just lift more weight and the
reason they do it is they've just done
it consistently longer
right or they're more consistent in
general they never don't do the basics
they always sleep they always do the
recovery mechanism they always eat the
macros that they're supposed to hit
right it's the same thing with business
and sales
like the best sales people are
consistent because they never don't do
the basics the tactics don't change it's
just your execution of them
all right and so when i look at
professional development so this is a
big zoom out but i think it's important
when i when i talk to higher level you
know entrepreneurs who are at like 10
million 20 million et cetera
and they're like what do i need to do to
you know to get to the next next thing
is
i see three major breaking points in
professional development as an
entrepreneur
the first is skills right people enter
the marketplace of entrepreneurship with
no skills
they have nothing to offer of value and
so they have to go acquire skills and
there's far more skills that you need to
acquire than you think
right you're like i need to be able to
get customers but be able to get
customers
is a lot of skills put together right
you have to know how to write copy you
don't have to
know how to create creative you have to
know how to build landing pages you
don't have to
have to have to be able to buy and place
traffic uh you don't
have to know how to nurture leads to get
them to show up to both schedule and
shop to a sales event
you have to know what type of sales
event you want to have is it going to be
a presentation is it going to be a
sales call is it going to be an
in-person appointment is it going to be
a two-step sale like
you have to know what the conversion
mech is it going to be a sales page
right
you have to know what the conversion
mechanism is going to be right and then
from there
you have to know the actual script and
closing mechanisms it's not just the
words it's how to say the words what the
tonality is how you ask the questions
how you confront obstacles how you
overcome them
how to process payments how like that
like this you know i mean like
the the number of skills stacks in order
to make it but its
skills is the first block right the
second block
is the character traits to execute the
skills
right as soon as you have your first
your first
box of tools what separates the people
who are really successful from the ones
who are just moderately successful is
that they have the patience the
endurance the discipline
right to execute their skills within a
defined way
and that is how they're able to
consistently grow because they're
consistently
executing and so it goes from needing to
acquire skills
in the beginning to needing to acquire
character traits which is why i love the
game of entrepreneurship is that the way
that you win consistently evolves
right it's literally not just more it's
different at every level
right and then that's kind of level two
is that you have to develop the
character traits to be able to execute
the skills
and then the third is your beliefs
right your beliefs about the world your
beliefs about the market your belief
about what's possible your tolerance
of what is acceptable in your
organization from an act
a standpoint of speed a standpoint of
excellence
and those beliefs are top down those are
from you
right and so as you move move through
i think it's cyclical right i think it's
every level
encompasses all three of those things
and you kind of have to spin your way
through the three of those things over
and over again and the reason it gets
difficult is that you still have to
maintain
the skills the beliefs the character
traits
of the base below before you can get to
the next level where you have new
beliefs
new skills new character traits that
need to be developed
and that's why i think most people love
entrepreneurship or at least hopefully
you like entrepreneurship if you're in
it
um is that it constantly forces you to
grow and growth is painful
right and so it's this weird masochistic
desire to continue to improve and yet
suffer the entire way
but love the process while you're
suffering so it's this kind of meta
thing but anyways i won't get too deep
into that
big point here is that if you're trying
to close and you're trying to get your
sales team to close
the person who cares the most about the
buyer will win
if the buyer cares more about their
outcome than you do then they will win
if you care more about their outcome
genuinely
than they do they will feel that a and b
when you confront their beliefs they'll
see it from a place of genuine care and
they will be real with you
and then when you get to the close
they're not going to bring their baggage
because you confronted the baggage
because you did it from a place of care
and then they will trust you in the
clothes to take them where they need to
go
all right so that's the big point that
was the big uh
that was one of the things that i'm
going to be i'm putting it to our sales
trading right now um hope you enjoyed
this if you did
drop a like or a comment if you didn't
still drop a like or a comment
all right anyways uh have an amazing
thursday i'll catch you guys soon
[Music]
you